Greetings everybody, my name is Sam Deiter, and I'm a Senior Unreal Engine Instructor with Epic Games.
In the following video tutorial series, we're going to take an introductory look at Chaos Clothing.
This is going to include us first talking about what Chaos Clothing is, and how it can be used inside of any of your Unreal Engine projects.
We're then going to take a look at creating content for Chaos Clothing, as there are some things that you need to be aware of
when you are creating the actual physical meshes inside of your Digital Content Creation Programs, or DCCs.
We're then going to have a look at the Chaos Clothing Editor as a whole, and understand the various tools and properties that are available for us to edit.
We'll then move on to the hands-on portion of this tutorial, where we will create a flag using Chaos Clothing.
And then finally we'll finish up with some Chaos Clothing tips and tricks to help you get the best out of your Chaos Clothing,
no matter what it's used for inside of your Unreal Engine 5 products.
We've got a lot to cover, so let's go ahead and get started with what is Chaos Clothing.